vous êtes peut-être un adepte des
randonnées à pied mais connaissez-vous
les randonnées à cheval aujourd'hui on
va tester la randonnée équestre dans la
forêt de rambouillet c'est parti on y va
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je me trouve chez cheval
nature aux tartes godrans avec lenny
gallego bonjour bonjour vous faites du
coup bas niveau confirmé mais aussi
niveau débutant comment ça se passe
comment faut venir habillés qu est ce qu
on doit apporter et bas nous alors pour
les débutants qui n'ont rien on dit
toujours jean baskets ou équivalent pas
se prendre trop la tête nous on va
prêter casque mini champ's
manteau de pluie petit peu pour que pour
qui sait pas besoin d'investir un
premier à monter à cheval le but c'est
de venir te faire plaisir de découvrir
le cheval peut nous apprendre adapte le
niveau et la durée en fonction du niveau
des cavaliers 6,6 et des débutants ont
fait des petites balades d'une heure une
heure et demie au pas avec
éventuellement un petit peu trop en
fonction des gens qui vont après avec le
niveau on va élever un peu les allures
et puis faire deux heures un peu plus
avec du trot et de galop pour les gens
qui savent noté merci beaucoup
lenny gallego nous on va se retrouver
tout de suite à cheval du coup pour
découvrir la forêt de rambouillet d'une
autre manière c'est parti
[Musique]
m
du coup est-ce qu'on est là déjà pour
commencer
l'été passé et qu'est ce qu'elle a de
spécial cette forêt de rambouillet a les
très gros
très variés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà cette journée est finie vous
insérez un petit peu plus maintenant sur
les randonnées équestres au coeur des
yvelines maintenant les chevaux sont
rentrés et c'est aussi l'heure pour moi
d'aller me décrotter
[Musique]